hey guys this is dennis the founder
thank you I'm doing Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of Zack Snyder's
Man of Steel yes Superman is back it's
back in back in fashion new suit a lot
of action you know this it's a new
Superman it's a Superman for our
generation yeah so overall I'd say um I
really liked it I can't say that I loved
it yeah just because there are some
issues here and there um but but I did
really like it how about you I agree I i
I'd really enjoyed it it's just some
issues with some of the story telling
you know the kind of this nonlinear
approach I didn't mind it but I felt
like the director Snyder and gore both a
writer needed to slow down yeah a little
bit I feel like they're trying to speed
through something that's like two and a
half hours but you guys can take your
time i'm probably get a second movie
going to tell a huge story in one move
and i think they were trying to do too
much in one movie but I still I still
enjoy us a lot a lot of fun yeah i think
the the main issues I had were when they
were kind of going back and showing a
the Clark Kent as the younger years it
was kind of like more like a montage of
events and and kind of the stuff that
you saw in the trailer was pretty much
it that's it they didn't like expand I
was hoping that there was going to be
like much more context for some of the
scenes and and but really they kind of
brushed over his own seem like a cliff
note version right of his path I wish I
would have spent more time in Smallville
I mean I kinda want to see more
interaction with his mom and dad and I
wanted to see more just more story along
along those lines I don't know I just
felt like they again rushed through it
and just like said okay we got to get to
this we get to the action we gotta keep
moving forward I'm like no like take
time and you know slow down a little bit
I also thought the visuals are really
really great oh yeah in the score hans
zimmer score was great you know Ian here
throughout yeah but and there's there's
lots of action almost in a sense too
much accident I think they especially
because they they weighed it all at the
end right you know I mean there's all
there's action throughout the movie but
they put a big chunk because there's
basically two giant
sequences right at the very end so it's
almost like 40 minutes of straight
straight action right it wasn't like
transformers heavy bad like you know
transformers 3 like we're just like an
hour of an action see wasn't quite that
bad but it was heavy where I was like I
would have liked a little more character
development and a little less action
even though the action was just
incredible I mean to fight sequences I
mean the punching the the main man they
got some property damage of in this
movie I don't even know how they get
away with all that but I mean it was
really really cool to see all that one
of the other things that i did--like i
like the fiora character see I wish I
was I love Michael Shannon but I almost
was she was in main villain Oh long cuz
i mean you know only look good you know
she's in that movie pandorum you know a
small sci-fi movie came out a few years
ago and she's good she was tough she's
ruthless yeah I liked her I liked her
the action scenes with her no Michael
Shannon is odd i am I thought it was
good you know um yeah the cast was it
was good that acting was good I just
think maybe some of the dialogue and
some of the right word could have been
ruined tightened up a bit and raiment
when I say tighten up it could be
expanded as well you know when I say
tighten up that doesn't mean we could
have been longer be shorter yeah tighten
up I mean things need to be I think put
in place right but I want to say to just
a good movie little praise here I
thought this is a time the first time
I've ever seen Superman actually be
Superman like in the old like you know
movies you know with Christopher Reeves
he's kind of flying like this and doing
this you know like throwing some you
know he's just kind of doing this thing
but this time we could see him punch and
hit and destroyed buildings and just fly
like me almost like like a speeding
bullet you don't like the old you know
show used to say so i think it was it
was great to see in this movie I she got
to see some awesome action sequences
with Superman fighting it felt like he
was the most powerful being on earth
yeah I think they're compensating for
superman returns because that was
something that that uh like having
bullets like flying hit you and hit your
eye okay come on yeah yeah so yeah like
I I liked it um obviously it's better
than superman returns but I actually
kind of also compare it to the Dark
Knight trilogy and I like it better than
dark knight rises
is but I don't like it as much as Batman
Begins or the dark knight I i agree i
think this this franchise is gonna have
a lot of potential obviously they've
green up the sequel so I mean Goyer and
Snyder I'm sure gonna stick with it
they're not gonna like fire them or
anything I don't think so yeah yeah I
mean these guys are this movies made
like 130 million in the opening weekend
so I I think that I hope that they can
learn from this movie and maybe see like
hey we did all this action maybe people
didn't want that much accident we can
tell more stories hopefully maybe we get
more story in a sequel I hope yeah maybe
we'll see Lex Luthor in the next one
what do you think about the the tone of
it like a lot of people complain that it
was too dark but I I actually didn't
have a problem with it not only goes to
dark i think the if anything it was too
dark is just the way they lit you know
that I thought the lighting but the
after-effects whatever they do to change
the look it looks like that that great
bluish-green that christopher nolan
loves cheese and dark knight rises but
the still story still had hope I mean
the whole thing is like you know you see
in the previews he's like you know look
this is what the symbol means it means
hope it's still that hopeful optimistic
he still has that kind of boy scout you
know mystique about him you know he
loves kansas jayhawks you know I mean
he's just a farm boy you know and that's
as simple as that I mean I don't think
it got too dark it wasn't Batman you
know wasn't he's not he's not brooding
like Bruce Wayne no he was a little emo
but it was his emails like um Peter
Parker wasn't amazing character was dark
what they did is because they want to
make the situation much more realistic
right and so I think the world around
him was was with darker than preserve
and people were expecting and and there
was a maybe a few jokes here and there
but like it wasn't like you know like
something like Avengers or iron man
there's Star Trek there's like a lot of
levity throughout it right where this
was only had like my like little spots
here and there every like right 20
minutes there be a joke or say I didn't
have as much fun watching as I did like
was an Avengers or star trek into
darkness it wasn't that kind of
excitement but it's still I still really
enjoyed it but yet I don't know it's not
it's interesting I think it was just
some of the things just the rushing of
the movie think that's what got me I
kept pulling me back a little bit like I
really wanted to get into ability just
say kept forcing it enforces I'm like no
slow down like I want to spend some more
time with Diane Lane as
ma kan who was awesome and kevin costner
who was like slow down i want ya like i
thought there was gonna be more than
especially kevin costner he was great
for scenes with with him cuz it's not
like you like i was thinking of know she
was thinking of Green Lantern Green
Lantern I didn't like green I know we
learn didn't had that great of a cast
I'm especially like ryan reynolds and
blake lively obviously Joe just wasn't a
good combination this movie had a great
cast is had all the actors in place that
they needed to make a good movie and
they could have spent time with them I
don't know why Snyder and greater files
needed to push to no rush rush rush and
like could have slowed down and spent a
lot of time with these actors who I
wanted to see more screen time with
especial side characters I guess one
also one of the problems I had with it
was there was a lot of exposition in the
dialogue like whenever they need to
explain something they kind of did they
didn't really show it they they kind of
said it they had a character say
something about either the situation or
about another character they're
terraforming was that well it's a
process above a livable a okay you know
like even like with Louis line I'm a
Pulitzer prize-winning journal you know
like no one phrases themselves like that
yeah you don't write so so I thought I
thought that was kind of one of the
things where they could have done a
better job of doing that well I think
I've realized in watching more of gores
work and I mean I watched a little bit
of da Vinci's demons which is on starz
right now watching this movie when he's
not with Jonathan Nolan and Christopher
Nolan writing stories I don't know how
strong of a writer he is I don't think
he's as strong as Christopher Nolan is
cuz we know what kind of I know helped
out I heard he had to kind of come in
and help out with this script a little
bit but gore I don't his dialogue isn't
the most it does it's not something
people can eat up and like you to spit
out it's like really good you know it's
just as well with the dialogue there
were some moments where they had some
good lines and the other he's awful
there be other times that there would be
like cheesy right yeah yeah so yeah it
was kind of like hit hit and miss right
I could tell like Christopher Nolan and
Jonathan Nolan weren't in this as much
as other in the Dark Knight stuff you
know then I can tell the reins a little
bit stronger or like inception a little
bit stronger but what do you think of
Lois Lane Amy Adams is Lois Lane Amy
Adams is a great actress I don't know if
I like her as lowest-lying i think it's
just she was miscast
not that I have an idea in my head to
put two who else would be in there but I
mean cuz Amy Adams is great but it's
just I don't know I didn't and if you
Lois Lane when I saw I didn't I don't
like you know Kidder either from the
original she didn't impress me so I've
never really seen a Lois Lane on-screen
rose really impressed with I don't know
it she's a good job she's great actors
but i don't i don't know i don't see her
like Terry hantaran Lois and Clark
that's like my favorite lowest which is
hatches beautiful woman yeah I actually
didn't my namee Adams as Lois Lane I I I
do think there's like certain things
that they kind of you know did with her
that that were more superficial than
like you know in get in-depth with her
character but right I mean even with
some of Clarke's stuff to it was a
little superficial yeah he I think the
they delve more into him is Superman
versus his like alter ego Clark Kent
right we didn't get a lot of this movie
I think that might be safe for the next
one hopefully get the next one I me know
they've supposedly greenlit a sequel so
this is a lot of possibilities in there
some Easter eggs you know hidden
throughout those people were speculating
about what the sequel might be about so
I think we'll get more of the alter ego
to Clark Kent in the next movie okay
before we get into our spoiler section
where we talk about the actual scenes
from the movie what would you give the
picture i give it a b-plus I say out of
the a range just because which is where
i put like avengers maybe Iron Man 3 the
kind of low a's or you know just regular
hey because it's just the felt a little
rushed to me and I wanted them to slow
down but otherwise I really enjoyed it
you know we just thought it's the second
time right now and I still like it yeah
I give it like a b /b plus it's kind of
in between I thought yeah the set we
just watch this for the second time and
I did enjoy enjoy it a lot more the
second time I think because my
expectations were so high the first time
I saw it and you know some of the parts
disappointed me and so seeing the second
time it was okay i know the flaws of it
so it was easier to kind of get over
some rat stuff um alright so let's talk
about some spoiler stuff let's get into
uh I think the main thing that
that people have been talking about is
is the ending yeah I ending with where
he kills Zod I actually really like that
I am NOT a Superman fan I did not read
any Superman comics I've read Superman
earth one you know by jaya jaya much
estrogen ski which is probably what this
movie's closest you know link to in
terms of comic books but I I like that I
even though no sermon doesn't kill he
always finds a way is always some way
out he can throw him in an open space or
something you know you can always find
something did not kill somebody but it
was realistic I mean he was put in an
impossible situation there was no other
alternative he had and he did mourn the
fact that he did that whole screaming
and kind of crying I mean I thought it
was a great scene I liked it because it
was unexpected what do you think that
too against Superman's character right
yeah I'm not one of those people who's
like beholdin to the comic books and
stuff like then I think it would not to
say okay it's like part of it Superman's
character to kill but in that situation
they made it kind of almost impossible
for him not to write yeah because if he
didn't then Oh family was dead yeah the
family was dead and in the way they had
kind of been building with Zod talking
about how Zod was you know never gonna
stop yeah he's bred I mean that's I mean
michael shannon is such a great job just
just you know dishing out those lines
you know just eating up those lines just
saying like look like this is where i
was born so it was made this is my
destiny this is who I am and yeah he was
fighting a guy against like that he was
never gonna stops only one way to stop
it unless you throw him in the Phantom
Zone was just too late everybody's gone
yeah I love all the lexcorp's stuff
there was even a wing underpriced I mean
all I've all the Easter eggs there's a
rumor going around this isn't confirmed
yet but when Superman's in the in the
ship when he first gets in the one
that's trapped in the ice for like 18
thousand years or whatever and there's a
pod that's open he kind of looks at it a
that that's the people are saying that
he could be Supergirl yeah there could
be super cuz there's a prequel comic
book that correct show like how that pod
got there and everything i'm down for
Supergirl for the next time down to see
that so I go to talk about the suit how
do you think it looked on camera I now
seeing it like you know I mean look cool
I mean obviously was a
be a more realistic suit made out of
like mesh my god and an explanation of
how he got it versus you know his mom
making it out of the law that was cut
you know or that he was wrapped in I
thought that was cool I like I didn't
have any issues with it I like the yeah
I like to some of the little
explanations like what the house sigils
and all that yeah I kind of like the
lecture detail they throw into this
movie so okay so how do you feel about
the the whole kind of Christian allegory
of of super the story of Superman Man of
Steel yeah because I mean it's very
apparent I mean oh yeah I mean he's 33
years old some Jesus died I mean a
parent I mean it's like the whole cry I
mean like I'm sending my only gotten son
to this world you like a guide humanity
and that's that's what that's the issue
with Superman that I have in the comics
I'm like how was this guy so faultless
like how was he without sin he's human
other people on his planet mess up other
people I was planning to have faults but
like he's always almost too perfect like
he never has any like he has Lois
doesn't really like have any cheating
problems like sometimes dates Wonder
Woman like I just he's not he's not
super relatable that's why I was happy
he killed Zod of the end I thought maybe
that'll help people kind of get into a
little more like that he was drinking
beer watching the Kansas Jayhawks
football game on TV he's bringing a bud
maybe that'll help but yeah that I don't
know I mean there was a scene where he
jumps out the the spaceship in space and
he's in the cross the ocean they go to
church and there's a there's a shot of
Clark and then you see Jesus back yeah
it's you know this planet for 33 years
it's like I mean it's not subtle I mean
right the movie is not subtle and every
writer and we read comics does it
differently some play that whole Christ
centric aspect of it some kind of less
on that this was a little bit heavy on
it I mean I get it I mean he is the most
christ-like figure in comic books I mean
least mainstream comic books but yeah it
was sometimes I was like okay it's like
easy guys you can read a little alright
guys so that's what we thought of a man
of steel you can post your comments
below on the website and on
a YouTube video and also come check us
out on twitter i'm at griffin de mine is
at think hero and make sure you
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
a think hero pro and we also have a
Facebook page that facebook.com slash
think your fans